>> MEIER: Good morning everyone and welcome
to the first ever episode of The Developers
Strike Back.
This is the opportunity for all of the developers
who we gave candid feedback to during the
App Clinic on Friday, and whose design skills
we tore apart on Android Design in Action,
just this last Tuesday to tell us exactly
what they think about what we told them.
My name is Reto.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm Ian.
Now, joining us today are four developers
not in the studio because I was able to file
a restraining order in time, but live via
Google+ Hangout.
And who are the developers today Reto?
>> MEIER: We have--we have a bunch of guys.
So, we've got Mattias from Yoga Timer.
We have Carlos from Timer, Alarm, Stopwatch
& Clock.
And that's right everyone I'm reading this
of a piece of paper in front of me.
Impetus developer Harry Ohra-aho and Hybrid--is
it Hybrid Timer, Hybrid Stopwatch, it's Javier
Salmona.
So, yeah, thank you guys for joining.
We're going to bring each of them up on screen
as we go through each of the apps and give
them a chance to tell us exactly what they
think of us.
I think before we get started we should remind
everyone of exactly what we were telling these
guys they should be doing last Friday.
And so that's the prescriptions for a great
timer or stopwatch apps.
So, again and these are things which I think
you guys are familiar with, you know, not
contradicting the design guide, having as
much functionality as possible, rich notifications
which really turned out to be a differentiator
for a lot of the apps I think and keeping
it simple.
So, as we--as we mentioned beforehand, these
are the apps which we're going to check out.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, you skipped user service
but I think that's because we--when we talked
about it, it really--using notifications and
applies a service anyway.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
Exactly.
So, we could tell that just from the fact
that everyone was using notifications one
way or the other.
So, let's see if we can spend a couple of
minutes introducing the folks.
So, if you want to try and bring everyone
up one at the time now.
We also got Roman.
I forgot Roman.
Hi Roman.
So, Roman is going to stand in for the Android
Design in Action Team and take all of the
constructive feedback that the developers
have around the redesigns which you guys did.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, do we have the beautiful
marks too?
>> MEIER: We do.
We have the beautiful marks setup which we
will put up before we talk about the each
app so, we're going toů
>> NI-LEWIS: Excellent.
>> MEIER: ůwe're going to put each of you
guys up on screen.
>> This is Carlos.
>> MEIER: So, this is Carlos.
Do you want to introduce yourself briefly,
tell us which app you are responsible for?
>> Yeah, of course.
Carlos from Barcelona.
I work in a company that works in developing
software for mobiles, iOS and Android, everything.
[INDISTINCT]
>> MEIER: Very cool.
So, we really like your app, Time, Alarm,
Stopwatch and Clock.
It was one of our favorites.
So, we'll look forward to checking it out.
>> NI-LEWIS: We like your Cydia too although
it's all sort of blur to me after MWC.
>> MEIER: Yeah, we were regular visitors to
Barcelona and yeah, we took our time.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Cool.
All right.
Soů
>> Next up is Harri.
>> MEIER: Let's go back.
So, this is Harri from Impetus.
>> OHRA-AHO: Yes.
Harri Ohra-aho from Finland.
Hello everybody.
And I'm a professional Java developer in a
company called Solita and I'm a sort of an
Android hobbyist by night.
>> MEIER: Awesome, awesome.
And so I think how a lot of us got started
with Android is--outside of our day job.
So, yeah, that's cool.
Thanks for joining us.
>> OHRA-AHO: Thank you.
>> Next is Javier.
I'll be translating for him.
>> MEIER: Javier.
And producer Daniel is going to be translating
for Javier.
So, this is the developer of Hybrid Stopwatch.
>> Cool.
Next stop is Mattias .
>> MEIER: Mattias , this is another friend
from the Nordics.
Developer of Yoga Timer.
I think you're muted.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think you're muted.
>> BERGANDER: Oh, that's why.
>> MEIER: Here you go.
>> BERGANDER: Thank you.
Yeah.
I'm developed the app Yoga Timer.
I'm from Sweden [INDISTINCT] and also a professional
Java developer from a company called Consat.
And I'm utilized into Android stuff during
my free time.
>> MEIER: Very cool.
It seems like a lot of Java developers up
on Nordics.
I wonder--I wonder where that could be.
So, as it happens we're going to start of
with Yoga Timer.
So, let's talk a little bit about that app.
So, could you maybe tell--as well, justů
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> BERGANDER: As you mentioned you have the
buttons on the bottom as well.
So, it was kind of hard to--I'm thinking about
the--some other apps that actually do something
nice or they don't show the ads the first
few days so you'd get used to the app and
feel that.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
It's actually interesting [INDISTINCT]
>> BERGANDER: That's kind of nice.
>> MEIER: I mean, one thing that you may want
to consider doing and I don't know how many
developers have sort of tried something like
this.
But something I--it could be interesting is
to actually have some A/B testing of your
app in the wild.
>> BERGANDER: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: So than you can basically randomly
decide between one or two different alternative
for ads and then try and measure the click
through rate and the effectiveness to see
whether, you know, are you getting more ad
impressions.
Are you getting people who continue using
the app more or less based on where those
ads go and that might be interesting to see
what some of the best alternatives are.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> BERGANDER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But, you know, the [INDISTINCT]
that I'm going to take from all of that is
Mattias was able to put together a completely
design guide complaint app when he was under
the gun.
>> MEIER: Very true.
Yeah.
Yeah, soů
>> BERGANDER: To a browser had a lot of nice
resources and you have a couple of nice guys
over at Google+ and you have the community
there and the [INDISTINCT] and app or UI patterns
and [INDISTINCT] I mean, you guys, there's
all the resource out there.
>> MEIER: Sweet.
Thank you for the compliments.
You're free gift will be in the mail.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Very timely we're up for review this quarter,
so.
>> MEIER: Perfect.
So, you know, we've only got the shorter shows
today.
So we're going to move along to the next app,
but thank you very much for joining us and
stick around.
Hopefully, we'll have a few minutes in the
end and we can bring [INDISTINCT] own back
together.
But thank you for this.
Thank for the app and for coming in the show.
>> I think Roman has a comment and he wants
to add.
Roll it.
>> MEIER: Oh, fire away Roman.
>> NURIK: Yeah.
A one super quick comment since you guys were
talking about kind of first time used.
So, in our design guidelines we have a section
on help, providing help but I also want to
call up this third party library called the
showcase of you on GitHub.
It has the kind of like circularly blue thing
that can highlight a specific you UI element.
That can highlight a specific UI element that
you want to kind of drive people towards to
any help, that's what you call.
>> MEIER: So, you thought using the same sort
of UI as the first you start Android and you
get the littleů
>> NURIK: Okay.
>> MEIER: ůwhen you hit the launch for the
first time, that sort of thing?
>> NURIK: Uh-hmm.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: Very cool, very cool.
Yes.
So, Roman makes sure you include a link on
the--on the event page.
Soů
>> NURIK: Will do.
>> MEIER: ůpeople can find that easily.
Excellent.
So, we're going to move on now to our next
app which is Timer, Alarm, Stopwatch & Clock
by Carlos.
>> NI-LEWIS: Carlos covers all the basis.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
So, absolutely nails the various things that
we said.
So, we'll going to quickly put up the prescriptions
that we had through and go through that first.
So, yeah.
Design guidelines, we gave a tick, time and
stopwatch.
So, I think the concerns here we had around
the rich notifications which weren't as rich
as some of the other apps.
And I think we were not in entirely convinced
that it was using a service in a right way.
I think that the stopwatch there was no notification
for stopwatchů
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ůwhich implied no ongoing notification.
So, do you want to tell us a little bit about
the app before we get too stuck in to the
review?
>> Yeah, yes, I am--years ago--few years ago,
I'm staying [INDISTINCT] and doing well at
some files [INDISTINCT].
I have to wait--I have to wait a couple of
seconds [INDISTINCT].
And I start to make my first app which is
called now.
>> MEIER: Very nice.
It's a beautiful looking app.
>> I mean [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> To learn more.
I used to [INDISTINCT] more and more and it
is a kind of [INDISTINCT].
Nowů
>> MEIER: Very coolů How you get on over
time.
All right.
We're going to--we're going to jump ahead
to the next app, just being conscious of time.
So, thank you very much for joining us today.
And stick around and hopefully we can have
another chat at the end.
But--yeah, thanks and congratulations on a
great app.
>> Okay.
Thank you.
>> MEIER: All right.
So, we're going to move on now to one of the
two apps that got reviewed during the--not
the Fridayů
>> NI-LEWIS: The weekly.
>> MEIER: ůthe Tuesday Android Design in
Action show.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: I'm struggling with my words today.
And it must be--because we're doing the show
earlier than we usually do.
I don't really get started before mid day.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
And you hadn't have enough coffee.
>> MEIER: No, no.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I haven't had another alcohol.
>> MEIER: No.
>> NI-LEWIS: I haveů
>> MEIER: Not enough of anything.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: So, this is--this is Impetus.
>> NI-LEWIS: I can work on that.
>> MEIER: We really do.
And this is from Harri who we have on screen
at the moment.
So hi, thank you for joining us.
You want to tell us a little bit about yourself
and about the app?
>> OHRA-AHO: Okay.
Thank you for having me.
So, Impetus it's--it came from--I'm--I have
been doing a lot of interval training of myself
for a couple of years, three years maybe.
And there were already a lot of timers for
this sort of specialized.
But they didn't have all the stuff I needed.
So, they didn't work reliably.
They had poor sort of audio or visual cues
and they--the sort of timing engine as didn't
have a sort of all the stuff I wanted to have
because I wanted to do sort of more complex
workoutsů
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> OHRA-AHO: ůthan they need--than they could
do.
So, this is sort of from my own need and then
I just wanted to publish it and see if somebody
else wants to have it.
So, what I aim for was sort of--you have to
have a really clearer display because when
doing interval training you're going to be
sort of exhausted and you can't see for five
meters ahead of you.
So, you have--so, you have to have some big
numbers and stuff like that.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
We can see that on the screen.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: You got the big bolds, you know,
bright white numbers which take up, you know,
a big part of the screen.
So, that'sů
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ůit's interesting.
>> OHRA-AHO: And then I want to have a landscape
mode because most didn't have it, so I have
dedicated it you for thatů
>> MEIER: Oh, cool.
>> OHRA-AHO: ůso it sort of changes to different
buttons and whatever.
And the--and then theů
>> MEIER: We didn't actually didn't looků
>> OHRA-AHO: ůthat sort ofů
>> MEIER: ůat the landscape mode when we
looked at it during the show that's--it's
definitely a best alternative.
>> OHRA-AHO: And then the--yeah.
Then the timing mechanics, I wanted to have
a timer that you can use if you just want
to have a really simple workout or if you
really want to go wild with something really
weird.
>> MEIER: Uh-huh.
>> OHRA-AHO: So, there's an two edit modes
so you can have a basic that you looked at.
So, there's such--sort of really normal work
and rest and whatever and rounds.
And then you have another sort of Mr. Hide,
you just met the--Dr. Jekyll, there's sort
of a Mr. Hide.
There's the advance mode where you can sort
of--there's a drag and drop interface in whatever.
It's a short for tree structure and with a
little loops and stuff like that.
It's pretty far out there.
So, I sort of wanted to push the limit of
what the internal timer can do.
So, you can have really many sets there, you
can have--like, you said in the options that
you can have pyramids where the time is sort
of alternating and stuff like that.
So, it'sů
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> OHRA-AHO: ůpretty advanced.
>> MEIER: Interesting.
So, yeah, I think--it's interesting I think
one of the challenges for the advance mode
where sort of playing with it on a screen
that you can't see.
Just to see sort of what you're talking about
and you write it, it looks like there's quite
an advance set of things that you can do.
I think--and maybe this is because neither
in--nor I--this kind of interval training,
I don't know.
I don't want to speak for you Ian.
Is this is what you disappear off to do every
evening?
>> NI-LEWIS: Not in this manner now.
>> MEIER: Not in this manner.
So, I think the fact that neither of us are
particularly experience for this makes it
a little bit harder to understand, but I think
the work flow around the advance sort of view
could be a little bit more intuitive.
It sort of doesn't give me a lot of help if
don't already know what I'm trying to do.
And this is an app you design for yourself
that makes perfect sense, right?
Because you just build the work flow thatů
>> OHRA-AHO: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ůmakes sense to you.
Or if it depends on the person.
Some people have it--that they don't really
understand anything, so that's true.
But, many people have said that, yeah, this
is--this is really the way to do it, that
they can sort of makeů
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> OHRA-AHO: ůtheir way around.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's all true.
I think I'm getting the hang on this.
Y
>> MEIER: Of course.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I don't think that's a bad interface at all.
You know actually what it reminds me a lot
of maybe because I've done--doing so much
and in the Adobe tools, you know, where you
remove layers and such so, yeah, I think there's
some--I see that'sů
>> MEIER: Yeah.
That makes sense, yeah.
We're playing with that--just off your camera.
I think the people watching at YouTube broadcast
can see, but yeah.
It's sort of--once you've add out a few things
it starts to make a lot of sense.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I think for something that's as complex is
this it's hard to see how it could get a whole
lot better.
I think maybe, you know, and an easier way
to add rounds for instanceů
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ůyou know, one thing that I've
appreciated about some programs like this
is that if you just drag things to the left
or to the right it'll sort of infer, you know,
okay you're dragging it to the right that
means you want it to be part of a set or aroundů
>> MEIER: As if you're trying toů
>> NI-LEWIS: ů[INDISTINCT] now.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Okay.
That's cool.
That's interesting.
I'm just going to bring up real quick the
tips that we had.
So, I think one of the things here was we
commented that it didn't have the really rich
notifications that some of the design elements
where a little bit off from what the design
guide says.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: And to the fact that it lacked the
stopwatch functions as well.
Frankly I think, you know, given what you've
described as the purpose for the app I think
it kind of make sense why there isn't a stopwatch
there to begin with, but I think again based
on what Ian was saying earlierů
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ůit's kind of a piece of functionality
you may want to have while you're doing this
sort of exercises as well.
Soů
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, let me--let me give you
example.
In this maybe unique for the way that I work
out, but sometimes I'll be working out, you
know, in some sort of timed manner and then
I'm just, you know, feeling really good I
want it to just keep going and so what I want
is--at the very least I want the timer to
countdown past zeroů
>> MEIER: And keep going?
>> NI-LEWIS: ůso I keep--yeah.
>> MEIER: That makes sense.
That makes sense.
I mean is that something that, you know, you're
interested in doing?
Do you want--do you--you know, [INDISTINCT]
it againstů
>> NI-LEWIS: Or is it just that I'm not nearly
is disciplined asů
>> MEIER: Maybe that's what you need less
stopwatches and more discipline.
>> NI-LEWIS: There you go.
>> MEIER: Well, what are your thoughts, you
know, is that piece of functionality and you'd
consider putting in or is that, you know,
to your mind sort of outside the scope of
what you're trying to build?
>> OHRA-AHO: Probably not to--as a sort of
dedicated feature because, yeah, it's out
of the scope.
But, there's sort of is a stopwatch there.
You don't have to--have to know it because
in the--in the--if you're using--there's a
sort of log there that you add there--you
can go to the preferences and then you're
going to add a third box in there actually.
>> MEIER: Oh.
>> OHRA-AHO: Which is the sort of a skip button
and you can't use a log that's once you--when
you punch it the skip a button it's going
to record the time that was elapsed.
>> MEIER: Oh.
>> NI-LEWIS: I see.
>> OHRA-AHO: At that point.
>> MEIER: Got it.
>> OHRA-AHO: In then you--in the end you're
going to have a sort of a rundown that you
took 15 seconds on the first interval then
you took a 25 and so on.
So, it is there but sure it's not too obvious.
>> MEIER: It's a little hidden.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Well you also have a shake to skip and shake
to startů
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ůwhich I think is really coolů
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: ůthat's sounds super useful
for a workout, you know, unless your hands
are [INDISTINCT]
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: And like--well, yeah.
But, I--it--yeah, this is--this is perennial
problem with all--well all applications in
general mobile apps especially this.
You know, how I would have found that unless
I was browsing through the setting menu which
a lot of people don't do.
Soů
>> OHRA-AHO: Yeah.
That's true.
>> NI-LEWIS: ůlike, they could probably--I
think that Roman's advice to use the--I'm
sorry.
What was the library called again?
Theů
>> Showcase to you.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Showcase to you.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Might help, you know, or a few--I
don't know.
I hesitate to use the word toast maybe something
that pops up, you know, when you take an action,
like, startingů
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ůyou know, it's kind of a did
you know you can also do this a different
way.
>> MEIER: Or you could in fact--I mean, in
this--I'd be interested to see what you guys
think of this.
But, one alternative might be to enable something,
like, shake skip and shake stop to begin with,
but the first time that it detects you doing
that rather than doing the action it says
"Hey shaking it like this is going to automatically
start, do you want to stop or disable this
action?"
So, you sort of opting people in by giving
them some warning as to what the hell is going
on.
>> NI-LEWIS: Sure and some--yeah.
I think we saw some of our music players did
that right.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: The shake thing to randomize.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Okay.
So, we're rapidly running out of time.
But, I just do want to pop up on screen.
So, we're looking at the redesign that we're
in the nick and Adam did on Tuesdayů
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: You know, did you get a chance to
have a look at their redesign?
What did you think of the suggestions they
had?
>> OHRA-AHO: Yeah.
I did and of course it's really beautiful
compared to what I have because they know
the stuff, so they're--maybe the problem is
that it's very out of context of course.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> OHRA-AHO: Because they've--they probably
be in sort of looking at the--my sort of basic
version, you knowů
>> MEIER: I would say that they'd be looking
at the Jekyll version for sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> OHRA-AHO: Yeah.
So, sort of--sort of putting it into my apps
or they maybe a bit more work because you
have to think about what it does to the advanced
side.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Absolutely, yeah.
>> OHRA-AHO: And theů
>> MEIER: I think it would be relatively straight
forward to put the simple case in, but you're
right, you want to keep that same look and
feel and functionality across the entire suiteů
>> OHRA-AHO: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ůand I think there's really a lot
more to it than that, so yeah.
Is--do you think it might be a direction that
you'll slowly try to head up?
>> OHRA-AHO: Yes, probably.
Becauseů
>> MEIER: Cool.
>> NI-LEWIS: ůI really have to--it's true
that--it's pretty difficult for somebody to
start using this, sort of fresh out of--when
you load it upů
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> OHRA-AHO: ůit doesn't really say much
what you have to do.
It's pretty professional sort of speaking.
So, it would--certainly help.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
I think that's, you know, the big challenge
right is that I think most of us because we
tend to be, you know, pretty keen on writing
code to just solve problems, right?
You have something that you need down so write
an app to take care of that and then you can
put it on Google Play really easy and to see
if there's anyone else who finds it useful.
And it's kind of not until you get to that
certain level of popularity that you like
actually, you know, maybe I should turn this
into something hat anyone can use.
And itů
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: ůcan be really--it can be a real
challenge.
Thanks a lotů
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, and a lot of it also is
finding your audience becauseů
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ůspecially when you're in a
crowded field like this.
You know, I know every time I've gone looking
for an app to suite a specific purpose and
I know I'm not the only one who does this.
I'll download five or ten apps.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And check them out really quickly.
>> MEIER: Yeah, right.
>> NI-LEWIS: And so there's some things in
this app where I'm thinking "Wow I--this is
exactly the feature that I wanted, but I didn't
even realized that it exist."
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I think that's really the
challenge for trying to monetize your apps
in Google Play is to convert people that need
what you're selling and want exactly what
you offer, but don't realize that you're the
guy that's going to give it to him.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
Except--you have like that 10, 20 seconds
when they first load the app to convince them
that this is the app that you need, stop looking
at everything else and that's a real challenge.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Cool.
Thank you very much for joining.
Again we're kind of out of time.
>> OHRA-AHO: Thank you.
>> MEIER: But, I do want to spend a couple
of minutes on Hybrid as well.
But, yeah, thanks for joining us and thanks
for--yeah, like, a great app.
And for showing usů
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm sorry.
>> MEIER: ůthe doctor--the Mr. Hide version
as well, that's definitely some interestingů
>> NI-LEWIS: It's really cool.
I like it a lot.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Nicely done.
>> OHRA-AHO: Thank you.
>> MEIER: Okay.
So, the next app we're going to have a look
at is the Hybrid Stopwatch and Timer by Javier
who I think is not entirely comfortable speaking
to us on camera, but we're going to put you
on camera and have--have Daniel read up anything
that you type to us.
So, if you want to give us a brief written
description, tell us a little bit about yourself
and the app, we'll have Daniel read it out
for usů
>> Yeah.
So, he actually has a description up here.
Let me go back up andů
>> MEIER: Excellent.
>> ůread it to you guys.
Javier Salmona from Chili, he's a graphic
designer and he is the author for Hybrid Stopwatch
and Timer.
And he's really happy to be here today with
us.
>> MEIER: Sweet.
We're really happy to have you.
This isů
>> NI-LEWIS: Graphic designer.
>> MEIER: This isů
>> NI-LEWIS: That answers a lotů
>> MEIER: So, this was the app which had an
incredible feature graphic.
Great icon, you open it up and has very distinctive
definitive look and feel and it's something
which in of all the apps that we had to look
at, this was the one I was most looking forward
to.
So, it really passes Ian's test of, you know,
I download a half a dozen which is the one
that jump most likely to use.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Most of them which leaves the impression,
so well done on a great looking app.
You know, I think, given the fact that you're
a designer and we have a limited time.
I think we should skip straight to the marks
and put them on screen.
And I think Roman, you actually were the one
which messed with this graphic designer's
wonderful work with an alternative suggestion.
So why don't we start by having Roman justify
what he [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Defend yourself Roman.
>> MEIER: And give Javier a chance at the
same time to maybe type down what you think
of what Roman has done to your beautiful work.
>> NURIK: So in the marks in here.
I think that it's pretty clear that we just
to a different direction, right?
There's --there's really, I mean, nothing
fundamentally wrong with creating a app that
uses a [INDISTINCT] I mean, it's certainly
if you want to make an app like that, that's
certainly your call, it's your application.
We just kind of thought, you know, what if
we were to take these features, the same set
of features, the same kind of identity of
the app and apply some of the Holo styling.
I think what we are trying to is, you know,
say it like, what it--would this make it feel
more Androidy, would make kind of users that
have, you know, newer devices down to Nexus
7 and so on.
Would it make them feel like this actually
is an app that's better, that belonged more,
we don't really know, right?
I mean, these are just mocks.
SO this is--this is not saying, you know,
like you should definitely follow this direction,
this is kind of a "What if' scenario."
>> MEIER: Sounds like [INDISTINCT]
>> NURIK: ůbut I think, fundamentally, the
one thing I did want to point out was just
the navigation.
So the one--the one non-visual concern was
navigation wasn't in any button in the legacy
menu button.
And that just, it's kind of difficult, I think
that it's--it's difficult to discover for
users and it's, kind of like a mash [INDISTINCT]
of navigation and actions.
And so, in the recent time that I did hat's
probably more important than the visual language
change was just the brining up the navigation
more forward and immediately up front for
the users.
The ability to toggle up with the stopwatch
and the timer and the ability to slide very
quickly between laps and the current stop
watch.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NURIK: So I think that'sů
>> MEIER: I think that's one of the big improvements,
I think, you know, in terms of the actual
look of the timer itself, I think, you know,
I could definitely go with the way out.
I quite like Roman's redesigning it.
It looks like something which would shift
with the phone.
If we have the timer or stopwatch built in,
I reckon it would look a lot like that, although
it probably be blue rather than orange.
>> NURIK: Yeah, that's just for [INDISTINCT]
just to exenterate but you can still theme,
right?
>> MEIER: Of course.
>> NURIK: I mean the original app has awesome
themes, you know, green, blue, pink, orange,
which is really awesome and great way to customize,
really simple way to customize.
And so you can do the same thing with Holo.
>> NI-LEWIS: I would love to see your take
Roman on the--a redesign of the skeuomorphic
design to be more in line with the navigation
that you're talking about, because I completely
agree with your analysis in navigation.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I also think that, you know,
looking--of course, we're looking at the initial
screen on the left here and then on the right,
we're looking at, that's the laps right?
>> NURIK: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I greatly prefer Roman's
redesign of that screen.
I felt like the original screen had too much
information compacted into small in area and
you know that one of my bad peeves is repeat
gradient designs on the list.
>> MEIER: Repeating gradients.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I feel like that.
>> MEIER: It sums a lot.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
That ship has sailed.
I feel the same way about the gradients on
the top of the left-hand screen, you know,
the timer--this sort of like, you know, pipe
effect.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Yeah, it's the pipe.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think it's--it feel--it feels--it
feels a little old, it feels less designed
than the main clock which looks amazing.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It uses gradients to give a very
realistic lighting effect on what looks like
a beautiful, you know, time piece.
>> MEIER: Oh, absolutely.
I would love a stop watch which looks like
that and now I can have one.
>> NI-LEWIS: There you go.
>> MEIER: Yeah, so I think, you know, from
my perspective.
I kind of like to see--like I agree again,
with the navigation, I think it much simpler.
The discoverability of the stopwatch and timer
in the laps and so on from the original design
is suboptimum, I think.
But having that beautiful skeuomorphic design
placed inside of the container that Roman
suggested, I think it would be a really nice
sort of compromise.
So, you know, what do you think Javier and,
you know, is--does the--does the navigational
alternative that Roman suggested sort of make
sense to you?
Is it a direction that, you know, think may
want ahead or you're just really happy with
the way that the app works now and think we
should just shut up?
>> Just go and give Javier a little bit of
time to respond.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Sure.
We'll wait.
>> MEIER: You should dance.
Roman?
There you go.
>> So Roman, why don't you go ahead and read
for him if you want.
>> NURIK: Yeah, sure, sure.
So [INDISTINCT] I think it looks great, I
like the Holo Android style and colors, the
current time and lap are easier to read and
understand with the change of color and topography.
The lap list main theme is the same looking
field, the analog view and the addition of
red and green values to show the slowest and
fastest laps is a nice touch.
Yeah, so definitely some of the elements can
kind of be merged in for sure.
>> MEIER: Very cool, yeah.
I mean, I think this is--this is an app that
really looks great.
That does the basics really, really well and
I mean, it just go such a stunning look.
And the way [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: And it really does andů
>> MEIER: ůand I like it, it's just incredible.
>> NI-LEWIS: And remember too, you know, a
lot of people joke about skeuomorphism, but
usually the objections are that it doesn't
add anything or that it actually makes thins
uglier, that makes things confusing or that's
presenting an interface that people that may
not be even familiar with because they haven't
grown up using the original equipment that
the skeuomorphism is based on.
>> MEIER: Indeed.
>> NI-LEWIS: None of those applied here.
I think that--like you said, I mean, this
is something that I'm really happy looking
at.
So I would love to explore more of how to
that sort of think but maintain all of the
Android navigation cues and UI cues that we're
used to in other apps.
Yeah, in general, I think it's really interesting
to look at both styles together and see how
you can accomplish this same thing in different
ways.
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
I think this actually brings up a really good
point that we sort of allude to during the
App Clinic quite often which is, if you're
going to do something that looks the same,
it should work the same.
But you can do something totally different
and as long as it looks good, that's sweet.
And so I think that's we're talking about
with this app.
Where the actual timer itself, you know, all
of this stuff here looks fantastic, it--and
it's intuitive.
And we've been working on clock design for
a fair number of years.
So it is something that people can intuit
pretty well.
That's kind of why it looks that way.
The things like navigation, you know, that's
going to be--should be consistent between
apps.
You know, you want to be able to flip between
apps and be able to navigate and find and
discover things, really easily.
And so that's kind of the sort of direction
you want to take when you're building an app
is try and keep the standard things which
are going to be the same as with a bunch of
other apps should be able to be accessed and
work the same.
And then things which are unique to your app,
make them unique, make them beautiful.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm going to make just one last
comment.
And that's that when I hit the set button,
think this is what I was most disappointed
with, is that we have a--so first off, this
is a less usable interface then a current
spinner based interface.
But also, the thing that kind of made me sad
was we have some really beautifully designed
buttons but then we also have this which is,
you know, beautiful in it's own way but during
next these.
>> MEIER: Yeah, right.
>> NI-LEWIS: And then these stock buttons
that I wish would just go away forever.
>> MEIER: So in case you guys can't see, but
we've actually got the set timer dialog up.
Which, yeah, it's unfortunate.
It's kind of being customized in a way that
probably made it look better on Gingerbread
or Frio or whatever device that you built
it on originally, but now on a--on a Jellybean
device, it looks a little faded, really.
So this is one example where the dialog could
probably stock to the defaults and you'd have
a better looking app now.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I think the general rule
is that if you're going to use a custom look
and feel, make sure that you use that all
the way throughout whatever view you're modifying.
Because if you incorporate stock elements
into a custom look and feel, then if the stock
elements ever change, which of course they
do because a lot of times manufacturers will
put on their own elements et cetera.
Then, you'll be stuck with elements that look
out of place [INDISTINCT]
>> MEIER: Cool, weů
>> NURIK: Javier just mentioned that he agrees
and he does want to change the time ticker.
>> MEIER: Also that's great.
I mean, we're looking--we're going to keep
an eye on this on Javier.
I think this is an app which looks great.
Has a, you know, a huge amount of potential
for something which is already really good.
So congratulations, thank you for coming on
and giving us your feedback as well and, yeah,
keep up the great work.
We look forward to seeing where this app ends
up.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Thanks a lot for joining us Javier.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
We're out of time because we thought this
would take us a half an hour and it didn't.
It'sů
>> NI-LEWIS: No, no.
>> MEIER: ůtaken us 45 and we've rushed.
So maybe now or next week, I'm not sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: Let's see--let's see what the
viewers think.
>> MEIER: Let's see, yeah, so let us know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Let's see if that hater comes
back from last week.
>> MEIER: Well, there are some people who
don't like fun and I fear that we may have
been smiling too much, so that could be a
problem.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's possible.
>> MEIER: But we do like to hear your feedback
and anything we can do differently, better;
longer show, shorter show; less of us, more
of someone else.
Do let us know, we'll try and take that into
account.
Quick heads up because we do like advertise
our own stuff.
This is something we've learn from watching
TV.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: On Friday, we have The App Clinic
once again me and Ian.
>> NI-LEWIS: Wait you got to do it the TV
way then.
>> MEIER: Goů
>> NI-LEWIS: Coming up next, Next week on
Android Developer live.
Go ahead.
>> MEIER: There's reason why we're not on
TV.
So we'll be up on Friday as usual, but not
as usual, it will be on at a different time.
So that's 10:30 in the AM.
That's Pacific Time, which is UTC minus seven.
We're going to try a little early because
we found a lot of--a lot of you guys are watching
us from Europe and this means you don't have
to stay up past midnight.
And may be that our audience is entirely made
of European insomniacs, in which case we are
really shooting ourselves in the foot here.
But we hope that this means more of you can
watch and take part.
We're going to do cameras and photography
apps, we've got a bunch of suggestions in
the moderator.
We're probably going go out of this broadcast
and start picking the apps.
So if you want to make a suggestion or vote
on the ones that are there, now is the time
to do it and we'll let you guys know exactly
who we're going to look at tomorrow later
today.
That's pretty much it from us.
We should take of.
Thanks for watching.
Again, let us know what you think.
We're going to--we plan to do the show weekly
to give all the developers a chance to let
us know what they think about what they told
them about their apps.
So do tune in and let us know what we can
do differently.
My name is Reto.
>> NI-LEWIS: And if you're watching and you
are a developer, make sure that you leave
your contact information for us so weů
>> MEIER: Absolutely, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ůget in touch with you.
>> MEIER: That's how we found all the guys
this week because they all commented in the
event stream.
So I was able to find them more easily.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: So let us know who you are.
>> NI-LEWIS: Any way, you were--you wereů
>> MEIER: I was doing a [INDISTINCT] Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
>> MEIER: So I'm Reto.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm Ian.
>> MEIER: And thank you very much for watching
and we'll see you tomorrow.
>> NI-LEWIS: Take care.